I danced with Bella for the first time
as by mir bist du Schoen filled the room
and her blue eyes locked with mine we
took turns singing and forgetting the
words she led I followed a waltz step
here a shimmy here hands on our hearts
our foreheads touching as we
communicated through movement and music
making sense tore nonsense
Bella is 83 and lives with dementia the
dance gives us a chance to find each
other how do I learn to dance with
dementia cos I'm not a dancer and I'm
not a doctor but I've played one in the
hospital I'm a clown doctor or a medical
clown my tools are whoopee cushions
shakers and a red nose you know the old
adage laughter is the best medicine I
hear that a lot now at the same time
they're studies to support it but right
now I'd like to take you behind the nose
and go beyond the laughter and share a
few things that I've seen skating
through icy use in my Healy's size-11
cuz I take medical clowning very very
seriously my mentor was conducting clown
rounds in the hospital when he was
approached by a nurse they needed to put
a tube up the kids nose kid didn't want
to do it so rather than hold the kid
down they asked my colleague if he could
help so the clown asked for a second
tube and shoved it up his own nose kind
of like this oh please don't do this at
home
now the kids saw this grabbed his own
tube and promptly stuck it up his own
nose kind of like this the clown's the
nurse and the patient discovered a
creative solution for their situation
together and guess what there's research
to back this up randomized control
trials in Israel and Italy show that
medical clowns can be as effective as
tranquilizers with no side effects in
2004 I started conducting my own clown
rounds at the Memorial Sloan Kettering
Cancer Center in New York City my
colleague and I were invited to
accompany a young six-year-old with the
most adorable southern accents to
accompany him while he got his
chemotherapy port flushed a very
uncomfortable and regular procedure we
joined him his mom and the nurse in this
tiny closed curtain cubicle every
medical clown encounter begins by
obtaining consent from the patient so we
ask him if we can be there he says sure
we're often the one element that the
child could control while they're in the
hospital so we start with a card trick
fan the deck so he can pick but as soon
as the nurse approaches with the needle
to flush the port he starts screaming
and cussing like no six-year-old I had
ever heard in my life so we say hey
should we come back later
he stops mouth open eyes wet with tears
face flushed pink with anger and he
smiles oh no you're fine now I want you
to be here okay so we start playing a
song my colleague on recorder me on
whoopee cushion the nurse approaches
with the needle and it happens again
this torrent of four-letter words he
went from playing and laughing -
screaming and crying back and forth
until the procedure was complete for the
first time I experienced this odd
duality of joy and suffering but not for
the last time see when we're there we're
not there merely to distract or make
anyone feel better per se the medical
clowns work moment by moment to create
connections between the clowns the nurse
the
parent and the child this provides a
source of power or control for the child
while supporting the staff with their
work I've spent over a decade bringing
joy and delight to the bedsides of
terminally ill children in the top
hospitals in New York City and you know
what I've learned everyone's hurting
staff family patients the patients in
the hospital because they're hurting the
family's hurting is they navigate
uncertainty grief and the financial
burdens of care the staff is hurting
only it's more than burn out more and
more health care workers or reporting
feeling overworked and overextended now
I'm not so naive as to suggest that the
solution is to send in the clowns but
what if what if the tools of Medical
clown arts practitioners from around the
world permeated our entire health care
system in 2018 at the Health Care
clowning international meeting they
represented over a hundred and fifty
programs in 50 different countries the
University of Haifa offers a formal
undergraduate degree program in medical
clowning Argentina has passed laws
requiring the presence of medical clowns
in public hospitals at their largest
province and this work affects more than
the patients it makes things better for
the whole healthcare team one of my
favorite games to play in the hospital
is elevator music I love elevators
because they're a place where paths
cross different worlds meet it's
intimate uncomfortably quiet and just
begging for a little playful disruption
the doors closed and The Girl From
Ipanema starts playing on Hammond organ
because I keep a portable speaker hidden
in my pocket so for those used to using
the silent sterile elevator it's a
moment of surprise
folks have permission to acknowledge or
not this disruption the game grows with
every stop because as soon as the
elevator stops the music stops new
passengers get on and the current
passengers get a witness the new
passengers they're surprised as they
hear the elevator music for the first
time you experience the shift of adults
standing silently straight
in an elevator to attempting to suppress
their mirth to is this a party or an
elevator filled with full-on laughter
research conducted in Brazil Australia
Canada and Germany confirm that the
artistic interventions of medical clowns
improve the work environment for the
staff beyond the elevator and support
their work administering care promising
research in the u.s. indicates that arts
programming in the hospital can't
improve the work environment leading to
increased job satisfaction and better
quality of care my work has taught me
how to actually be present how to
breathe in the room with a person in
pain how to connect and build trust no
matter the age ability or illness and
how medical clowning is an excellent way
of using the arts to put the care back
in health care Thanks
[Applause]